en este vídeo quiero continuar
explorando las propiedades de las
funciones trigonométricas hiperbólicas
pero antes que nada vamos a hacer un
repaso muy breve de la trigonometría
usual así que bien si empezamos
considerando la ecuación en el plano
cartesiano x cuadrada más ye cuadrada
igual a 1 esto que nos define pues nos
define un objeto que ya conoce muy bien
que es el círculo unitario déjenme lo
intentó graficar
e intentó graficar por aquí vamos a
decir que aquí tengo
esto es x igual a 1 esto es x igual a
menos 1
por acá tendríamos ya igual a menos 1 y
acá tendríamos de igual a 1 entonces mi
círculo unitario se vería algo así
algo así que bueno no me quedo muy bien
que digamos pero ustedes son la idea
espero esto estaría aquí más arriba y
tendría de igual a uno bien entonces
nosotros sabemos que si consideramos x
igual a x igual a coseno de t
y la seno de t para algún parámetro t
entonces por la definición misma de las
funciones trigonométricas x cuadrado más
y cuadrado es igual a 1 y entonces para
cualquier valor de t obtengo un punto en
esta circunferencia de hecho te lo que
me mide es el ángulo que se forma con el
eje real positivo esto de aquí sería el
ángulo t bien entonces suficiente repaso
vamos a considerar ahora otra cosa vamos
a cambiar completamente el panorama
consideremos ahora la ecuación la
ecuación x al cuadrado menos llega al
cuadrado igual a 1 y lo que nos va a dar
esto el conjunto de las equis y las que
satisfacen esto lo vamos a llamar la
hipérbole
hipérbola
unitaria
en analogía con el círculo unitario
claramente y como se ve este conjunto
pues lo voy a intentar graficar
de antemano una disculpa porque
seguramente me va a quedar un dibujo muy
feo
pero espero que puedan usar su
imaginación y compensar mis errores
entonces aquí tendríamos el punto x
igual a 1 por acá tenemos el punto x
igual a menos 1 que observen que estos
dos puntos son donde la hipérbola corta
el eje x y bien pues de nuestros vídeos
de secciones cónicas nosotros sabemos
que está esta hipérbola tiene como assín
todas las rectas de igual a equis la
dibujo esa es mi recta de igual a x y de
igual a menos x ye igual a menos x por
eso casi casi no aparece una recta pero
bueno entonces la hipérbola se ve algo
así se empieza a acercar a su asiento
está pero nunca la toca y obviamente
continúa hacia allá
igual hacia este lado
se empieza a acercar a acercar acercar
pero nunca la toca y también por acá
bien algo así se ve la hipérbole
unitaria entonces no sería padre no
sería algo interesante que esta
hipérbola unitaria tuviera una
parametrización análoga a la
parametrización del círculo unitario
pues la respuesta es que sí la tiene
supongo que ya se imaginan quiénes van a
ser las funciones que me permitirán
parametrizar la vamos a decir qué
x
coseno hiperbólico de t
lo que definimos en el vídeo pasado
recuerden coseno hiperbólico de teherán
que a la t
más y al menos te
entre 2 y vamos a decir también que yo
es igual a seno hiperbólico de t
a la t - al menos t entre dos de este
lado para cualquier valor de t que
eligiéramos obteníamos un punto en el
círculo unitario será cierto que para
cualquier valor de t acá obtenemos un
punto en la hipérbole unitaria pues
vamos a checarlo si ese fuera el caso
entonces tendríamos que x cuadrada menos
10 cuadrada debería ser igual a 1 pero
quien es x cuadrada menos de cuadrada
pues x cuadrada sería lo mismo que
coseno hiperbólico al cuadrado que sería
lo mismo que esto al cuadrado pero qué
es eso al cuadrado si elevó el numerador
al cuadrado obtengo a la 2 t que sería a
la t al cuadrado más dos veces dos veces
ella late por la menos t más
al menos 2 t
simplemente tome esto como un binomio y
lo eleve al cuadrado
todo eso dividido entre 2 al cuadrado
que es 4 ya eso le tengo que quitar
menos que al cuadrado que sería seno
hiperbólico al cuadrado que viene siendo
a las 12 menos en este caso
alarte por la menos de
más
al menos 2 t
todo eso entre 4 noten que este menos
afecta a todo esto bien ahora cuánto
vale eso déjenme lo escribo por acá
y vamos a poner denominador común 4
bien antes que nada un par de
simplificaciones observaciones quienes
tienes ya late por él a menos de pues
esto es lo mismo que ella late menos te
que es sencillamente a la cero que es
uno así que estoy aquí es un 1 y estoy
acá también es 1 así que
esto se convierte en el 2t + 2 x 1 que
es 2 más
al menos 2 t y ahora menos
a la 12 sólo estoy distribuyendo al
menos aquí menos por menos es más
más dos porque es 2 por 1
- por más es menos menos al menos 2 t
acabe mi renglón bien pues ahora noten
algo muy bueno este término cancela a
este término y este término cancela a
este término así que obtengo 2 + 2 entre
4 que es lo mismo que 4 entre cuatro que
es 1
así que de hecho si obtuvimos un punto
en la hipérbola unitaria si satisface la
ecuación que queríamos pero noten que a
diferencia en el círculo unitario donde
al variar te recorría todo el círculo
unitario en este caso al variar t solo
me muevo en la rama derecha de la
hipérbola y la razón de eso está aquí en
la definición del coseno hiperbólico
porque si se fijan esto sólo puede ser
positivo
solo
puede
positivo
positivo y la razón de eso es que la
exponencial de cualquier número siempre
es un número positivo al menos para
valores reales así que este número de
aquí siempre es positivo empezamos
hablando de la fórmula de hoy leer en el
vídeo pasado y definimos el coste en hoy
al psoe no en términos de exponenciales
complejas
luego quitamos la parte compleja y nos
quedamos con esta definición de kossen
hiperbólico y seno hiperbólico y ahora
encontramos esta relación maravillosa
entre las funciones trigonométricas
habituales y estas funciones que ahora
sí tenemos derecho a llamar las
funciones trigonométricas hiperbólicas
pues se relacionan con el per bolón
unitario